this morning Americans are being urged
to reconsider travel to China over fears
of possible wrongful detention it comes
as treasury secretary Janet Yellen is
set to visit the country this week Face
the Nation moderator and chief Foreign
Affairs correspondent Margaret Brennan
recently traveled to Beijing where
there's a concern a new Chinese counter
Espionage law could put foreign
companies at risk
Chinese State TV broadcast these images
of police raiding the Shanghai offices
of U.S firm cap Vision
Chinese authorities claimed it was an
ordinary Law Enforcement Act it happened
to four or five of our firms over the
last couple of weeks U.S ambassador to
China Nick Burns told Chinese officials
the U.S is deeply concerned by this
intimidation these are punitive actions
and they're unwarranted and they're
often you know the Chinese take these
actions they rate an American firm they
find them they jail the employees Bain
and Mintz other U.S consulting firms
have also been targeted all of these
companies conduct market research for
Western firms to invest in China it is
part of President XI jinping's expanding
control of the state and business which
may complicate his attempts to court
American Investment
Burns says the issue is a broad new
Espionage law that cracks down on data
collection which opens up Americans to
criminal prosecution for simply
conducting what would be a normal
business activity in any other country
Roberta Lipson runs a private Hospital
group in China where she has lived since
the 1980s American companies are
concerned because of the ambiguity of
the regulations and not really
understanding what they're about she
used to urge for the government to
regulate now she worries new
restrictions will hurt medical research
and argues it would be disastrous for
both the U.S and China if businesses
pulled out being here makes us better
being here makes us want to be better
than all of the other competition for
CBS mornings I'm Margaret Brennan